Good afternoon everybody! You're an
amazing crowd. Somebody walks up to the
microphone and it gets quiet. Like you
don't even have to ask, you know, "May I
have your attention please?" So you're
already winners today. I'm very
excited that we are together this
afternoon because I believe it's
something really special that we're
doing now. We can save the judgement
until after this session today, but
events like this are so important
because they push us to think about who
we are as people, what we stand for as an
institution, how we must stay connected
to the world and how we can learn from
each other. And I think you're really
going to enjoy the panel today and we're
extremely fortunate to have Peter Hart
with us. He is quite famous - he wouldn't
know it because he wouldn't tell you - he
is a quite famous person, a pollster. He
works with NBC, The Wall Street Journal,
he has managed some of the most
difficult town halls. So the fact that
he was willing to work with us at Emory
to engage in what we're calling
"conversations with America" was quite
remarkable. I'd like to talk just for
a second about these conversations with
America. People have asked me, "So it
sounds really interesting but why are we
doing this?" and I think everybody in this
room I'm gonna assume - and if you
disagree don't tell me now tell me later -
you know it's so easy, at universities in
particular, we're all smart people, all
people that are thinking about what's
the evidence for what we're looking at,
we're all people who believe that we
know how to make a case in an argument.
We talk a lot to each other
and before we know it we forget what the
rest of the world thinks. And I don't
know if you ever have had this
experience. I recently have had to take a
few trips away from Atlanta into more
rural areas of Georgia, North Carolina,
South Carolina, and I'm not always good at
making sure that I have enough gas in my
car. So then I find myself at quite
unusual gas stations and two things
happen: I sort of listen, I'm eavesdropping to what people are talking
about and  I'm like "boy this is like a
different planet and this is not just
like a few hundred miles away". The next
interesting exchange is I
start to pay and I say something and
people look at me as if I am a too alien
because I don't sound like them at all.
So in all of this we reinforce the notion
that that we are a part of a very
complex diverse world, and that's why
we're having these conversations with
America, to really break through the
bubble that we live in and to get a good
sense of what the rest of the world
thinks. You'll hear a lot more about those
conversations later today as the
panelists talk, as Peter sets it up. And
I'm really not going to say much more
but I would like to highlight a few
aspects. One of the areas that I'm
extremely proud of, for us as an Emory
community, is that we are not afraid to
have difficult conversations, that were
not afraid to tackle sort of the
impossible questions. That we are also
not so arrogant that we know what the
answers are, but we're just willing to
take a risk and challenge ourselves and
thereby really advancing the world,
really helping the world come up with
some of the complex issues that we have.
As a social scientist and a public
health expert, I actually have some of
the people in the room know, my COO
Harris here - he and I have known each
other for a very long time - we have been
working on addiction for quite an
extensive period of time, but there's
something that's different about the
opioid epidemic that we currently have
in the United States. And I'm not gonna
take the time to give you a lecture on
what I think is different about it, but
some of you might have seen my recent Op-Ed
piece on CNN, where you can get a
sense of what I'm thinking about. And one
of the aspects of that, that I just can't
help myself but will have to say. For
those of you who don't know, I grew up in
the Netherlands. I spent the first three
decades of my life mainly in Europe and
addiction is all over the world. It's not
something that happens only in certain
places. But the approach towards people
who have an issue with addiction, people
who whose habits get out of hand is that
you can approach it in different ways. So
I come from a culture and I strongly
believe in a philosophy that if somebody
has a problem - in this case
with opioids - the last thing we should do
is blame the person and turn him into a
criminal - him or her into a criminal.
Because at the end of the day addiction
is a societal problem. It's a problem for
all of us. It's a sign that something is
wrong in the world in which we live. And
that means that we collectively really
are responsible for not stigmatizing
people, for thinking about solutions, and
for having the kind of conversations
that we're going to have a day. So I want
to thank you for your commitment to
being here, to be part of this
conversation, to learn from each other,
and I hope that you really will enjoy it.
And I now invite the panel to get going
and for me to get out of the way. Thank
you very much!
[audience applauds]
President Sterk, thank you very much. I'm
delighted to be here I've been in the
public opinion field for for now over 50
years, and I've been taking the NBC Wall
Street Journal poll for about 30 years
now. And what we, as a society, we've made
such an unbelievable advancement in so
many areas. Whether it be in terms of
race or religion or in terms of marriage
and all of the other elements, and you
would say this has been remarkable. But
at the same time we've been doing this,
what's happened is we've really become
polarized as a society. And it's no
longer a chance that we talk to one
another and that we've reached an area
of consensus. And so what Emory has
undertaken here is the importance of
beginning a conversation, the ability to
be able to talk to one another to figure
out how you reach a consensus. Because as
you watch with the United States
Congress just last week, and weekend, and
week out, there is no consensus that is
being built. And so whether it be the
issue of immigration, which we undertook
in the fall, or the issue of opioids
which is so important, that we're
undertaking now, what this is about is
having an understanding and a dialogue.
Last year we lost 63 thousand Americans
to opioid overdose at a rate that -
although there are some hopeful signs
here and there - continues to increase
around the country. We live in a country
that has six percent of the world's
population. We consume 96 percent of the
opioid medications or opioids produced
in the world. Something is particularly
wrong in this country.
Right now about 230 million prescriptions for
opioids in the US on an annual basis,
enough for every single adult to have a
bottle of pills around the clock for
three weeks.
That's too much. And we have decreased
prescribing in the past few years, but
we're at three times what we were in
1999. So when people say we've
drastically reduced prescribing, no.
The curve was going like this [indicates steep upward direction with hand]
now it's going
like this [indicates flat outward direction with hand]
so there's still room to go.
And my concern is that we've primed the
pump and so a lot of people became
addicted to these prescription pills, and
then have gone on to misuse or use
heroin and now fentanyl, which we know is
just killing people due to the potency.
So we really, you know, got this guideline
to really change practice. It's a
guideline, it's not a regulation, but it's
really talking about how non-opioid
should be used for chronic pain first, so
that people have evidence-based
treatment. Because that's what's about -
when you look at long term evidence - for
opioids for chronic pain it's not there.
For acute pain, sure. Chronic pain, the
evidence isn't there.
The reason I'm here
is because I'm a parent who lost a child
to an accidental overdose. It happened
right down the street. It happened
Thanksgiving of 2013. Laura Hope was a
senior in high school. That's the new
face of addiction. If you , in my opinion,
and it's not unlike anybody else who has
family around here. But part of her,
she had suffered a jaw injury. A broken
jaw right here at Decatur High School,
soccer match. She was a varsity
goalie as a freshman playing against Decatur High, got a boot to the jaw. While all that
sounds very innocent, it happens in
sports, it's an example of how it might put a
young person on a path that they might not be able to get off of. And in her case she
was prescribed liquid Lortab. As a
personal long-term recovery at that time,
I knew about my issues but I didn't know
the ramifications of a opioid being
prescribed to a person, a young person of
aged 15, what it does to the brain and
how much they like it so fast and they
stay on it. Through statistics it'll say, if
you're exposed to an opioid before 21,
you have 80% chance of a substance use
disorder. If you make it to past 21
you've got a 80% chance of not
suffering from addiction, from substance, or opioid - you know prescription
turning into an addiction. So those are
things that I've unfortunately learned
in my journey since then.
[audience member] I work with a
program here in Georgia called
Motherhood Beyond Bars and we teach
prenatal classes at the Department of
Corrections. The vast majority of the
pregnant women in the Department of
Corrections are there for drug offenses
or crimes related to it. And to me it's
probably one of the most devastating
views of this crisis, to see a pregnant
woman in prison attire serving time
while she's pregnant and then being
separated from her baby, and just the
cycle that it creates in these families.
[another audience member] There was a wonderful book called Pain:
The Gift That Nobody Wants by Dr.
Bradley and Yancey, and they talk about,
you know when you have leprosy pain, the
lack of pain is a real problem. You lose
a limb. But I have noticed with our
patients that they don't want any pain.
Sometimes part of healing and part of
that pain does promote healing. So I
think a cultural change and a shift in
how what the expectations of people are
would help.
[another audience member]
What is the rate of patients,
who had legal prescriptions for opiates,
that become addicted? And that's not from
like family members borrowing or
stealing.
That's patients who have been prescribed
for like a surgery and then after the
surgery they ended up turning to
something worse or non prescribed opiates.
[panel answers] And what I would tell you is that we don't
have great data on that. And that's what
the issue is. Like when we look at the
incidence of new addictions in our
country we can't give you that number. We
can tell you prevalence rates of
addiction. And a lot of times it depends
too on how long the prescription was for
and the initial strength. And that's what
we see is makes you more likely to get
addicted. Usually for somebody who's just
on opioids for chronic pain, I
believe the rate is less than 2% that go
on to get addicted. But when you look at
how many, if you've got 235 million
prescriptions out there, 2%, then that
number gets big.
So for me, this issue is epiphenomenon of so much.
It's epiphenomenon of our relationship to
drugs in general. I mean opioids
are scary because they have such
terrible results, but I worry how many of
our students, you know, are on cocaine taking
Adderall when it's not prescribed, I
worry about that. I worry about why are
so many of Americans feeling so
desperate. What that to me, this
epiphenomenon of a societal illness of 21st century America, that we in a sense
refuse to address by focusing on other
things, which is not to say that opioids
aren't as a terrible problem, but I guess
to President Sterk's
earlier point, if we can't see - that there
are actually - this is actually a scream
for help, we are going to miss the boat
on so much.
[Peter Hart]
It doesn't stop here, this is
where it should start. It's the beginning
of a conversation, an important
conversation, so give yourselves a round
of applause and thank you very much for
going there.
[audience applauds]